i learned that you never really cared
about dressing up and dragged you were
in a rock band right and there was a
gimmick involved dressing up as a woman
you're absolutely right it was it was a
gimmick in fact we were doing it back
then as a statement to say you know
listen we're told not is really like a
punk rock statement we're not we're told
not to dress and drag so we're going to
dress in drag did you get a sexual
thrill out of dressing and drag no do
you like the attention from men yes the
power part which is i guess sexual too
um the power you get it's like uh clark
kent to superman the power you're
getting the attention and somehow when
i'm in drag the frequency is clear for
people to pick up on me like you know
i'd be ignored
normally right if you were dressed as a
man no one would pay attention to you
right i'm not even sure how the whole
big rupaul thing blew up i mean you
became very famous from a hit song right
yeah you know what happened i was
downtown this is when there was a club
culture in new york city big mega clubs
they pay people to come and go go dance
drag queens and whatever everything come
and dance and show up there so i i
really hit the pinnacle i become the
queen of manhattan which is this big
honor that
was there a contest yeah oh yeah
but who teaches you how to be a drag
queen how do you learn how to do
something like that well in the drag
world there are say mothers and fathers
and people who um i i lived in atlanta
georgia for many many years and and
that's like mecca for for drag queens
this is
and so uh you know there were a lot of
people that we uh emulated but we were
like a new wave of drag we were i
started out doing gender [ __ ] which is
like you know combat boots and smeared
lipsticks sort of like this hey you know
[ __ ] you not sure what i am boy or a
girl exactly exactly so but then when i
moved to new york uh that wasn't really
happening i had to make money and so the
call then if you want to make money was
for
femi pretty uh you know shave your legs
put on some fake tits and you did it
well where do you think you shine the
most i probably shine the most in drag
and drag yeah
it's kind of a drag going back to being
a man right i mean in a man's outfit
well not really i mean it's obvious it's
more comfortable at least when you when
you do drag when i do drag there's so
much attention on me and and you have to
sort of be a conduit to so much energy
that you know i'm i'm happy to take it
off so i can go because i'm actually a
very chill person you can actually move
around in life very comfortably because
absolutely yeah that's actually a good
good thing and it's by design i mean we
live in a patriarchal culture that is
designed for men to be men and listen
doing dragon a patriarchal culture is
akin to treason the most punk rock thing
you could do